HEARING TO OR THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS
CALLED ORDER WE WILL OPERATE
UNDER A SUBCOMMITTEE AS WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM YET. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
MEASURES ARE CONSENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE IS YOUR ONE OH SEVEN
FILE ITEM TO ACR ONE TWELVE
FILE ITEM THREE ACR ONE
NINETEEN FILE ITEM FOR ACR ONE
TWENTY FILE ITEM FIVE ACR ONE
TWENTY FOUR. WHILE I'M SIX ACR
ONE SEVEN FILE ITEM SEVEN EIGHT
ZERO ONE TWENTY EIGHT. FILE
ITEM EIGHT S. C. R. FORTY SIX
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE S. YOUR
FOR FIFTY SIX. MEMBERS THIS IS
A SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO
HEARING OF THEREFORE WE'RE
HEARING THESE BILLS CONSIDER
WHETHER TO RECOMMEND TO THE
FLOOR CONCURRING IN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THAT WILL BE THE
MOTION FOR EACH OF THESE BILLS
WE DO HAVE A AUTHOR. WHAT WE
DID MR BIGELOW WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROCEED TO THE PODIUM. IT WILL
BE HERE AB SEVEN FIFTY NINE. I
LIKE ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY NINE REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION TO
UPDATE THEIR GUIDANCE TO
SPECIFY APPROPRIATE PA POSITIVE
PROTECTION MEASURES THEY CAN
USE TO HELP ISOLATE WORKERS OR
WORK SOUNDS FROM TRAFFIC US
HAZARDS THIS BILL IS ABOUT
SAVING THE LIVES OF THOSE ON
OUR HIGHWAYS AS WELL AS THOSE
THAT ARE WORKING THE HIGHWAYS
AS WELL NO EVERY YEAR WE EACH
SEE. A SEA OF. CALTRANS. PARK
RUN HERE IT TO THE CALTRANS
MEMORIAL AND RECOGNITION OF
THOSE WHO HAVE GIVEN THEIR
LIVES. TO SERVICE IN OUR GREAT
STATE THIS PARTICULAR BILL WILL
REACH OUT AND TRY TO HELP. CURB
THOSE INCIDENTS. WHERE WE'VE
LOST LIVES OR HAD PEOPLE
INJURED. I THINK EACH OF YOU
HAVE SEEN THIS BILL YOU'VE READ
IT YOU UNDERSTAND IT SO I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND CHEN AYE VOTE. ON THIS
MEASURE. YOU HAVE THE WITNESSES
WERE MISTER BIGELOW. I DON'T
BELIEVE. I DON'T BELIEVE IT
THEY HAVE SHOWN UP NORMALLY I
DO HAVE A TO FOLKS BUT THIS IS
A SHORT HEARING SO I HOPE THAT
WILL. MAKE IT COMFORTABLE FOR
ALL. THANKS VERY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC FEEL LIKE SAYS FINES FOR
THE AUTHORS BILL. DONE HE IS
THE PUBLIC LIVES WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION CHAU
CONCERNS OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SIGNAL QUESTIONS OF ANY ERA
MONTHS WE HAVE FORMAL. NOW WE
HAVE A SECOND OKAY. SOUNDS GOOD
AS WE KNOW MISTER BIGELOW THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
WE'VE WORKED WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT PARTIES AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE AFFECTED BY
THIS AND HOPEFULLY WITH
RESOLVED EVERYTHING TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR
SATISFACTION AS WELL AS THE
OTHER COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
MEMBER SATISFACTION AND I JUST
ENCOURAGE AYE VOTE ALL THE
MEMBERS. FROM ALL THE MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISS REGULAR. FOR
BRING THIS ISSUE FORWARD I HOPE
THIS DOES MAKE OUR ROADS SAFE
RIGHT TO. ATTEND THE CALTRANS
MORRELL EVERY YEAR FOR THE FALL
WORKERS AND- I APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS TO PROTECT THE CREWS
OUT THERE. WHEN WE DO ACHIEVING
A QUORUM WE WILL TAKE A AND.
ROLL CALL VOTE ON. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE HAVE. WE HAVE A QUORUM
LOOKS LIKE MAD SENATOR PLEASE
CALL. YEAH. YEAH YEAH. THE
TICKETS FOR ATTENDANCE FRAZIER.
FONG AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN YOUR
BIGELOW PRESENT JUNE CUNNINGHAM
DALY. DEEP FRIEDMAN GIPSON HERE
GRAYSON. MEDINA YOUR NAZARIAN
O'DONNELL. SO WE HAVE A QUORUM
WE HAD A MOTION FROM MISTER
DALY IS SECOND FROM MISTER
GIBSON. WHAT DO AFTER THAT. SO
WE ARE ON THE SERVER THEY LOW'S
BILL WILL GO AHEAD IN TAKE A
VOTE MAPS ARE VERY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS A
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE FONG. FONG
I AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN HI
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW
AYE CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY
AYE DEEP FRIEDMAN ABSENT ARE
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
MEDINA MEDINA I IN THIS AREA
O'DONNELL. BEEN DOING. THIS
PEOPLE IS LIKE THAT ON. FOR AB
TWO SEVENTY NINE THE MOTION IS
TO CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
DEEP. DEEP I THANK YOU FOR THAT
ONE. THE ROLE BEEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS MISTER BIGELOW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MEMBERS WE WANT
TO THE CONCERNED CALENDARS IS
THERE A MOTION ON THE WORLD. WE
HAVE FIRST A SECOND TERM AND
SURGERY PLEASE CALL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FRAZIER
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE AYE
GEAR CURRY. BERMAN HI BERMAN
AYE BIGELOW. A LOW IQ
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN GIPSON AYE
GIPSON I AGREE SEN. HE SAID I
MEDINA MEDINA AINDA SYRIAN
O'DONNELL. CONSENT HAS NINE
LEAVE ROLLED IN FROM SOME
MEMBERS THE TIME PERIOD MISTER
LACKEY AB EIGHT THIRTY THREE
PLEASE. BUT FOR TO YOUR BRIEF
STATEMENT MISTER LACKEY. I LOOK
FOR TO ATTACH CONCLUSION ALSO.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT THIS BILL. IT
CLARIFIES ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE MONTHLY
PARKING CITATION PAYMENT PLAN
CREATED BY THE LEGISLATURE BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THE
CITATIONS OF A PERSON RECEIVE
MORE THAN ONE COULD NOT
AGGREGAE TO AN AMOUNT MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS. AND
LATE FEES AND PENALTIES
ASSESSMENTS WERE TO BE WAIVED.
HOWEVER SOME CITIES ARE
CALCULATING THE BASE. FEE OF
THE CITATION LATE FEES AND
PENALTIES ASSESSMENTS AND OTHER
THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR CAP WHICH
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES ACCESS TO
THE PAYMENT PLAN. THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THE LATE FEES AND
PENALTIES ASSESSMENTS ARE NOT
ONLY WAVED ONCE. IT ROLLED INTO
THE PAPER PLAN BUT ALSO TO BE%
CALCULATED INTO THE THREE
HUNDRED DOLLAR CAP USED
DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
REASONABLE. CLARIFICATION.
THANK YOU MISTER LIKE ANY WITH
THIS IS A SPORT MY ANGER AN
ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THIS CHAIR MICRO WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR THAT. WAS
THE PUBLIC WHO LIKE TO TEST
FIND SOME MORE THE AUTHORS BILL.
HE REMEMBERS THE PUBLIC FEEL
LIKE TO SHARE CONCERNS OR IN
OPPOSITION WE AUTHORS BILL.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS. THE STRIKE IT WAS
LIKE TO CLOSE OR ASK YOUR
SUPPORT IN THIS REASONABLE
APPROACH. AND I AGREE WITH
LACKEY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
KEEPING AND CONTINUE THIS WORK
I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
FRAZIER. HI FRAZIER AYE FONG
FONG I AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN AYE
AYE BERMAN AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW
IQ. CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY AYE
DEEP. I FRIEDMAN. GIPSON GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
AND I IN THIS AREA AND
O'DONNELL. AS DRIVERS WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OR FORGIVENESS
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER LACKEY THANK YOU
. ON AB
SEVEN FIFTY NINE BIGELOW THE
MOTION IS TO CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS CHIU. CHIU I
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN HI. ON AB
EIGHT THIRTY THREE LACKEY THE
MOTION IS TO CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS CHIU. TWO BUY
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE. WE HAVE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR MISTER
CHAIR. HI MR CHIU FIVE MISTER
NAZARIAN MISTER NAZARIAN AYE
.
ALL
. SIX FIFTY NINE BIGELOW THE
MOTION IS TO CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS AGUIAR-CURRY. I AB
EIGHT THIRTY THREE LACKEY THE
MOTION IS TO CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE. WHEN I JUST
WANT TO HAVE FUN. SHE'S COMING
YEAH YEAH. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN HIGH ON AB AB FIFTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN I AB
EIGHT THIRTY THREE THE MOTION
IS TAKEN CURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AYE
. CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL AYE. AB SEVEN FIVE
NINE BIGELOW THE MOTION IS TO
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL FINE. AB EIGHT THIRTY
THREE LACKEY THE MOTION IS TO
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL AYE. THANKS.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FOURTEEN EYES. AB EIGHT A. B.
SEVEN FIVE NINE BIGELOW THE
MOTION TO CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN HIGHEST. AB
EIGHT THIRTY THREE LACKEY THE
MOTION IS TO CONCUR ON SENATE
AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN EYES.
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS FOR THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS NOW COMPLETE THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED